the big question that I think needs to
be answered is how can we provide
entrepreneurial education to the poorest
of the poor access to education as we
know it is no longer sufficient or valid
only access to education but education
that has no quality does not produce any
tangible results many of the world's
poor have access to education and in
fact have been to 3rd 6th 9th grade that
has not changed anything so what we need
is practical intrapreneurial education
to everybody in order to obtain the
resources to provide this education we
think that education should pay for
itself or cope pay for itself by income
generating educational programs on
campus with it teachers and with the
students but we think that if we do not
do something with quality education
right now we will not be able to
overcome the challenges that we're
facing right now thank you very much